Сергій Кравцов - викладач в одному з київських університетів.
Щойно пункт вакцинації розгорнули на його місці роботи, Сергій одразу зробив щеплення від ковіду.
Минуло півроку. Зі ЗМІ чоловік довідався, що через 4-6 місяців ефективність
вакцини суттєво знижується. Тож, чоловік разом з родиною готовий
вакцинуватися втретє, аби посилити захист.
Я сподіваюся, що ми отримаємо якомога швидше. Змінюється сам вірус,
ефективність знижується. Але це все одно набагато краще, ніж якби я не був вакцинований.
Окрім імунного захисту, Сергій також хотів би щепитися бустерною вакциною
з практичних міркувань. Його дружина отримала дві дози CoronaVac,
а Сергій щепився Pfizer. Тепер вони не можуть поїхати до низки країн разом,
куди з китайським "коронаваком" не пускають. Сергій сподівається,
що бустер німецько-американською вакциною зможе вирішити цю проблему.
До того, що в Україні досі немає можливості щепитися третьою вакциною,
у Сергія двояке ставлення.
З одного боку, я розумію, що це буде не зовсім справедливо, якщо хтось отримає ще одну дозу,
поки хтось ще не отримав перші дві. Якщо я не маю можливості,
тобто я наче забираю у когось дозу - тоді так, це несправедливо.
Але ці інші просто не хочуть, і їх вмовляють, коли інші вже хочуть
- то це дві сторони одного питання.
Головна мета бустеру - посилити захист, оскільки через пів року після вакцинації
кількість антитіл у крові різко зменшується. Це вже засвідчило чимало
міжнародних досліджень. Ізраїль був однією з перших країн, яка запровадила
масове третє щеплення від COVID-19. Успіх був моментальний
- у країні різко знизився добовий приріст заражень. Тепер через поширення омікрону,
нового варіанту коронавірусу, такі країни як США, Великобританія, Німеччина
офіційно закликають всіх дорослих громадян щеплюватися втретє.
Експерти прогнозують, що незабаром чимало країн вимагатимуть
третього щеплення для перетину їхніх кордонів.
То коли такі охочі, як Сергій, зможуть отримати третє щеплення в Україні?
На запит DW, у міністерстві охорони здоров'я відповіли, що бустерна доза буде,
але за певних умов.
Однак така заява викликає ще більше питань. Вакцинація в Україні розпочалася в лютому,
і за 11 місяців двічі вакцинувалися лише 29% населення. Навіть попри те, що
в листопаді у країні запровадили жорсткі обмеження для нещеплених.
Співзасновник Українського центру охорони здоров'я Павло Ковтонюк вважає,
що український уряд копіює ідею з 50% щеплених для бустеру із західних країн.
Однак це неефективне рішення, оскільки в Європі темпи вакцинації набагато вищі.
Тобто 50% ми, дай Боже, дочекаємося в принципі у 2022 році.
Зараз швидко падають темпи вакцинації. І як показує досвід наших сусідів
у Східній Європі, десь на 30-40% просто завмре кампанія. Бо людей,
які мають ентузіазм вакцинуватися - їх приблизно така кількість.
І тоді що? Ми чекатимемо вічно цих 50%? Тому я за те, щоб в Україні
бустерні дози починати робити швидко, напевно, навіть з Нового року.
На думку експерта, причина, чому мінохоронздоров'я відтягує старт бустерного щеплення,
організаційна. В Україні доволі складно керувати кампанією вакцинації,
оскільки тут мікс вакцин з різним періодом очікування між двома дозами.
Впровадження бустерних щеплень, та ще й поспіхом, може створити організаційний хаос.
Робити бустерні дози - це додаткові серйозні організаційні зусилля,
це ще один рівень управління цим процесом. Коли одні люди будуть мати 0 доз,
інші вже 3. При чому різними вакцинами. Це все дуже важливо тримати купи,
бо людям потрібні будуть ці сертифікати, їм потрібно самим управляти
своєю вакцинацією, і це все стане дуже непросто.
Медики в пунктах вакцинації також відчули спад попиту на щеплення.
Наприклад, у цьому київському пункті після введення обмежень
для невакцинованих у листопаді щеплювалися приблизно 300 людей на день.
Тепер - удвічі менше. Попри це, медичний персонал регулярно
отримує запити від людей щодо третьої дози.
Кожен раз питають. Ми кажемо, що так, вона буде, кажемо, що вона буде
приблизно пів року після другої дози, але це приблизно, ми чекаємо на наказ.
Ми позитивно ставимося, немає ніяких проблем в цьому.
Водночас процедура надання третьої дози в Україні досі не затверджена.
Тому лікарі не можуть давати рекомендації пацієнтам, наприклад,
чи можна змішувати різні типи вакцин.
Я зараз сама не знаю, яка буде процедура. Наприклад, як лікарка я вакцинувалася
наприкінці лютого "астразенекою". Я би хотіла бустерну вакцину теж "астразенеку",
це моя улюблена, але це персонально. Я поважаю всі вакцини.
Може, бустерна буде не "астразенека", а якась, наприклад, Файзер - я ще не знаю.
Я чекаю на наказ, тоді це буде коректно пояснювати.
Та навіть попри відсутність інформації, люди в черзі на щеплення
готові отримати й бустерну дозу - за необхідності.
Якщо це буде потрібно, і я після цих вакцин почуватиму себе нормально, зроблю третю.
Можу і п'яту зробити, мені воно байдуже.
Звичайно, якщо треба буде - будемо робити. Тому що хочеться бути вільною людиною.
Пересуватися, ходити в театри, їздити за кордон.
Якщо треба буде - так, буду. Не боюся, це ж для життя.
Давайте доживемо. Треба жити сьогоднішнім днем.
Якщо треба буде - зробимо.
Я не знаю, якщо чесно. Я ще не думала про це.
Якщо вимагатимуть для подорожей - я зроблю.
Досвід інших країн показує, що бустерна доза справді дієва у боротьбі з пандемією.
Науковці стверджують, що захист після третьої дози буде довготривалішим,
ніж після перших двох. Чи означає це, що щеплюватися від ковіду тепер доведеться
кожні пів року? Науковці поки не мають одностайної відповіді.
Це залежить від того, як поведе себе вірус: чи після кількох сплесків сам ослабне,
чи стане ендемічним - тобто назавжди залишиться з нами, зазнаючи постійних мутацій.
Вірусологи сподіваються на колективний імунітет, що звело би пандемію нанівець.
Поки цього не сталося, вони радять не розслаблятись і не нехтувати можливістю
зробити вакцинацію третьою, "бустерною" дозою вакцини.
Коли це стане можливим в Україні - нині залежить від мінохоронздоров'я.